Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie.
This is going to be my Game of Thrones video
for favorite debunked theories like the most
crazy ridiculous theories that have since
been debunked.
So just careful for spoilers for everything
that the TV show has done so far. Because we're
so deep into the break before Game of Thrones
season seven gets here I want to be doing
a lot of fun theory videos like this.
This is more about the craziest theories, but
be sure to subscribe to get everything and
make sure you enable alerts.
YouTube is doing some weird stuff right now.
So you might not see everything so when you
subscribe make sure that the bell is grayed
out so crazy Game of Thrones theories, number
10.
A lot of you have heard the R plus L equals
J theory; Jon Snow is the son of Rhaegar Targaryen
and Lyanna Stark.
So there's a counter theory to that, that Jon
is secretly the son of Ned Stark and Lyanna
Stark, and there was a twincest situation, which
just makes your head spin because we know
sometime after the tourney of Harrenhal, Rhaegar
absconded with Lyanna Stark, seemingly capturing
her.
So it set off the chain of events that led
to Robert's Rebellion. Between that time in
the end of Robert's Rebellion, when Ned Stark
finally found Lyanna in the Tower of Joy in this,
you know, pool of blood, more than a year
had passed.
Meaning that she could not have been pregnant
by Ned Stark.
So first big theory debunked, and you didn't
even need to watch season six to do it.
You literally could have just looked at the timeline.
One of the things that Martin does in the
books is spell dates out, so he gives you
the clues you need to parse the timeline.
So even though the series has not officially
confirmed R plus L equals J, it is definitely
not N plus L equals J. Thank God. Number nine,
There a lot of theories about people secretly
being other people. You're not a character
in Game of Thrones until you might secretly
be another character in disguise.
So there was a theory that Benjen Stark
was secretly Daario and had gone to make a
new life in the East, like he just completely
bailed on the Watch. Now we know the TV show
is just a little different from the books,
and what the TV show has done is use Bengen
as Cold Hands from the books. Cold Hands
is sort of like this half turned White Walker,
who still has a little bit of his mind left
and is able to help Bran Stark as he's going
to see the last greenseer.
So even though the show has used Bengen in
a slightly different way from the books, Martin
has said that he will eventually pop back
up again.
Meaning that Daario has to be another character.
Next big one, number eight, Roose Bolton is
actually a half-human, half-other, skin changer
who has used the faces of the people he's
flayed - House Bolton, the flayed man - to survive
for a long time in disguise.
So he's an extremely long-lived person, just masquerading as this lord of Westeros.
So what this is is kind of like a version
of Arya walking around, changing her face, killing
the people on her list, as we saw that she
started to do at the end of season six, in
the idea that there was something more sinister
behind Roose Bolton's evil.
But as we know from the TV show, from the books,
Roose is just a terrible, terrible person. The
story that he told Ramsey about his mother
was horrifying, how he basically raped her, killed
the woman's husband, then when she came back
later with the baby Ramsey, almost decided
to kill him, but took him in out of the kindness
of his heart. What a charitable person. It almost made you feel a little bad for Ramsey
after that. Of course Ramsey himself is
a very terrible person.
The show did heighten him just a little bit.
He's a terrible person in the books, but he's
not quite as big a character as he was on
the TV show. It's just that there's fewer characters
on the TV show so it's seemingly focused on
him more.
But you've heard about the prophecy, the three
heads of the dragon, you know - number seven -
there was a theory,
this is so great, that the three heads of the dragon were Samwell Tarley, Mance Rayder, and Hodor.
So the three heads of the dragon are these
mythical people that get tied up in the prophecy
of the Prince who was Promised, and will serve
as something of like a last defense against
the White Walkers and the new Long Night. Rhaegar
spoke the prophecy, Daenerys heard it when
she was in the House of the Undying. They didn't
quite do it on the TV show, it's a much bigger
scene in the books - but effectively what the
show has put forward so far says that Daenerys,
Jon Snow, and Tyrion will probably be the three
heads of the dragon. Now that might be a slight
change from the books, but most of the evidence
is pointing towards them - especially scenes
like this, where Tyrion talks about how much
he wanted a dragon as a child, and now the
dragons seemingly trust him.
So there's a whole bunch of other stuff that
goes into dragon riding, dragon bonding, but
the three heads of the dragon is mostly a
prophecy that talks about the three most important
people in the War for the Dawn. So Samwell,
still a very critical character for learning
important information on fighting white walkers,
probably not gonna be riding any dragons, anytime
soon.
The next one - number six - is a really good one
too. The Arya fight club theory that she imagine
the waif in her head.  There was actually, this is one of my more favorite debunked theories,
but since they wrapped season six, the actors,
the producers, the people that were actually
there filming those scenes, said no, you know,
we weren't doing any crazy fight club stuff. This
was Arya just fighting someone who hated her,
who just also happened to be from Westeros.
The waif actually came from a fairly similar
background to Arya. She was originally born
into one of the lesser noble houses, not nearly
as great a house as House Stark, but through violent
means, found herself going to the East, at the
House of Black and White to become a faceless
person.
So her main problem with Arya, the main reason
why she was fighting her so much, was because
she felt she was not committed, fully committed
to their cause - and it's actually true Arya
did decide to go back to Westeros.
So, there are actually some pretty good behind-the-scenes theories about why George RR Martin
wrote that storyline when they could've had
Arya train in Westeros - but that's like
a whole other video. "Game of Thrones: Abandoned
Plot Lines and Things That Change from
George RR Martin's Original Outline." Next one, also
really good one - number five - Sansa was pregnant
with Ramsey's baby. This has actually been confirmed by actors more recently,
where they have reiterated, no, Sansa is
NOT pregnant. The whole reason this got started
was because, when they were promoting season
six, they released a couple photos and Sansa
had a dress that was just really bulky like
the winter coat that she escaped in, when
she and Theon were running from Ramsey's dogs.
She looked like she had this bulge in her dress,
so people thought that might mean that she's
pregnant - but the timeline didn't work out,
and it was just a really WTF twist the people
were hoping were true, just because the show
had been piling on Sansa so much, since season
five, with this whole Ramsey storyline.
Let's see how much we can drag her through the mud.
And even when he met his untimely end at the
mouths of his own dogs and said to Sansa some
of me is inside of you.
He implied that there was some of him that
would live on in her he was mostly talking
about the seed of evil, but some people doubled
down on the pregnant Sansa theory and felt
like this meant that she actually had like
a literal baby, literal Ramsey seed growing
inside of her, but since then the actors have
confirmed this is not the case.
So no pregnant Sansa. Next one - number four -
Martin is a big Tolkien fan, as we all are,
but some people believe that Westeros,
"A Song of Ice and Fire", the world itself is just
the world of the "Lord of the Rings" stories'
Middle Earth 2000 years after the events of
"Lord of the Rings."
So it's crazy, but some people did believe
that "A Song of Ice and Fire" really was
Tolkien fanfic - but typically what people point to when they say why "A Song of Ice and Fire" is so much
better than other fantasy literature, is that
it doesn't fall into the tropes of recycling
Tolkien.
So Martin went out of his way to not do Tolkien, so it's like the complete opposite.
But some people, looking at the map and feeling
that both of the series that pull from real
life events, like a lot of Game of Thrones
is based on real life events in and around
Western Europe.
So is Tolkien, so they must be the same
planet. But it's just another big theory that is
been debunked. Number three - we know that time
travel exists, a form of time travel, because
Bran is the last greenseer now, and he can
use the weirwoods to astral project himself
into the past. The show has played it a little
fast and loose with whether or not he can
directly affect the past - seemingly Ned Stark
hears something when Bran calls out to him,
but that's mostly them messing with us a
little bit.
There is a time travel theory that does not
involve Bran.
There was a very well thought out, but misguided
theory that Tyrion is secretly the son of
Khal Drago and Daenerys, thanks to blood magic.
Now it just sounds so crazy that already you kind
of dismiss it, but it was so well thought out,
and so crazy, people were fascinated with the
idea - but we know that Mirri Maz Duur's blood magic
effectively traded Rhaegal, her baby, for
Drogo, who came back in this sort of half-life,
half-death state, and ended up dying again.
So that in and of itself became the catalyst
for the hatching of her dragons. Blood pays
for blood.
So really the blood magic just led to the
hatching of her dragons, that was really all
that was about. But even when you get into
crazy blood magic, Tyrion's birth was witnessed
by other people just in the way that Daenerys'
birth was witnessed by people. So - number two -
slightly more plausible but still pretty ridiculous,
Ned Stark, secretly a warg, left his body and
is still alive out there somewhere today. But
the problem with that is that Ned Stark's
death is this huge catalyst for the story,
so it was necessary that he die and it would
be a big middle finger to take that back this
late in the game.
And the reason why it's just a little bit better
in terms of crazy theories that have been
debunked, is that Martin has confirmed that
all the Stark children, and Ned Stark too, have
wolf dreams. That does not mean that they're
all wargs, it just means they have the potential
to become wargs if they develop the ability.
But in most of them it goes unpracticed, especially
someone like Ned Stark.
So even if he did have wolf dreams, and he
could have warged had he been a really bad-ass
warg in that moment, he was not and ended
up dying. But Nymeria and Ghost are still alive,
so there are still people that could warg into
their direwolves in the future if they want
to go that direction. But number one -
this is actually like a really good crazy
theory.
This is one of my favorites so far. So there
was a theory that Hodor was secretly the
great other controlling the white walkers.
So this theory popped up sometime before we
saw that season six episode where we learn
the origin of Hodor's name. But as important
as his character was, he's largely this mundane
person who just helps out and winds up tied
up in saving Bran, so that he can go on and
do the things that he needs to do. So very
critical, very heartbreaking ending, but he's
not meant to be anything more than the person
who helps Bran get away from the Night King -
that he goes all the way back in that big-time
loop.
So just the mechanics of what actually happened
on the show, like the truth, made people's head
spin.
So theories like this actually don't sound
that crazy, but when you actually think about
it Hodor secretly being the Night King, who
himself was chasing them down, just sounds
completely ridiculous. So let me know in the
comments, what is your favorite craziest Game
of Thrones theory that has been debunked since
the series started? It could be a book theory,
it could be a TV show theory.
There are so many bad ones out there that
are so much fun to read later on. Like I didn't
include it on the list, but there was the theory
that Varys was really a merman because he
was not afraid of the water, which already
just sounds ridiculous.
So that's how most of these debunked theories
go.
They have like a little bit of truth to them
because of some moment that happens, or a character
exchange - but what's going to happen is is I will do
some more theory videos in the next couple
weeks for theories that I actually think are
true and do have a basis in reality. But if there
are special theories, or even prophecies that you
guys want me to do longer videos about, just let me
know in the comments - and I'll say congratulations
to this week's giveaway winner 729Drew, you
win a $20 Amazon gift card. Please private
message me on the back end of my channel so
I can get your contact details. And a new round
of the giveaway starts now. All you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video. So, just a reminder, just
because YouTube is being
weird right now, make sure
you enable alerts like make sure that bell
is grayed out and actually this avatar reminds
me.
Rick and Morty season three is getting ready
to get started.
I will be doing videos for it.
the first video will drop in the next week.
So The Walking Dead coming later tonight Rick
and Morty coming later this week if you guys
haven't seen it it's one of the best new animated
series in the last couple of years I started
watching while you guys wait for that to post
you can click here for that season 7 teaser
trailer and you can click here for my season
7 predictions.
Thank you so much watching everybody high
five I'll see you guys tonight!